This is a I history of France,
uh,
1871 to the present and I'm,
my name's Mirman and uh,
we meet Monday and Wednesday in this room,
which is a pretty good room.
And we the third,
the famous third hour to be arranged as
a section a at the moment we have been
assigned 40 aes.
They'll looking around,
we won't need for case,
but at the moment,
uh,
we have [inaudible],
we have Michael [inaudible],
we have a on today,
Yvonne Yvonne level.
And we have a Brian Riley and um,
knowledge of,
of Francher or anything at all about
France is not required in this class at
all.
Somebody who had my introductory class,
lots of you haven't,
a couple of you who had the,
the first half of this course.
I'm,
most of you haven't.
I'm going of you won't
be here the next day.
Uh,
that's the,
the,
what happens with shopping period.
And then the third day we
see how many folks we have.
We do have for those people who want to
take it a total deletional Fonsi don't
go,
we have a section that's French speaking.
It's an idea that the Chris Miller and
the French department and I came up with
in the late nineties,
and my old dear friend,
Dick broadhead provided the funding.
And what this is,
is that if you want to
take the section in French,
uh,
I,
you know,
you should have about a
equivalent of one 30 I,
and the discussions in France
and a couple of the books,
I'll talk about them in a minute.
You can read in French,
others you read in English and it's not,
you know,
it's not a lot.
He does a thing where we're,
I mean,
I'll tell,
I'll tell you once,
there was a student in there
who had really fantastic,
uh,
French,
and I said,
why is your French so good?
And the person looked at me and said,
well,
the maid was from digital,
you know,
and another time somebody
French's are good.
And I said,
why is your French so good?
Well,
you know,
mummy used to take us
to Shamani for the pool,
uh,
leave a constant Devad and it's,
you know,
or you know,
our apartment next to the
Turkey feather that was a,
gave me contact with different people.
Um,
and so,
uh,
it's not like that.
I assure you it's truly
isn't and you're not,
you're not counted off for,
uh,
you know,
for errors that you make.
And in writing either.
I,
if you're writing in
French and it really rocks.
Trust me,
we've done this for year after year one
year we actually had something like 42
people signed up on the
course was much bigger.
Uh,
and we thought they all thought they were
getting a free prize or something for
signing up.
There were so many of them.
We end up with about 32.
We've had a few as eight.
As long as we have five,
it will,
it will go.
But it's a lot.
It's really fun.
And a,
you'll know people around here,
if you're a above a first year student
who have taken this and it really rocks,
it's really great.
Uh,
and Brian Riley's going
to going to do this.
He's from the French department.
So I would encourage you if you
have a as that kind of interest to,
uh,
to do that,
um,
and you won't regret it.
There's never been anybody
who regretted doing it.
Um,
and it's,
it's just a lot of fun.
The other sections we'll meet in English,
uh,
and uh,
you know,
usually what we do in this course as
we offer some nights sections because
people are kind of busy.
And so we,
there'll be certainly a
section on Wednesday at seven,
certainly one Wednesday at eight.
Uh,
there'll be certainly a,
uh,
sections,
Thursday at one 30 and two 30.
And the French section is
tentatively scheduled for,
what did we say?
We said Wednesday at one 30.
It wasn't that it or something like that.
It all shakes down and it is fun.
Now,
what,
what are you going to do
in the course will be,
we have to come with good humor
and that I hope you'll have,
um,
it come to the lectures
and do the reading,
see the films,
which I'll talk about in a
while and go to sections,
uh,
and uh,
hopefully participate in sections
and the sections tend to be fun,
uh,
in this course.
So,
um,
so far I know you're dying to know
about midterm and final and those direct
wretched things.
I wouldn't give a midterm because I think
it's a waste of time except we have to
um,
have some sort of,
it gives you an indication how
you're doing in the course.
If you screw it up,
we don't count it as
much as if you do well.
Um,
and the final is we will give you on the
last day of class the questions for the
final,
we give you six questions and we will ask
you on the day of the final to respond
to three of those.
Our choice,
it would be hardly sporting if
you've got to pick the three.
Um,
and we also give you an
oral exam option that,
uh,
if you want to say not be
here on a Christmas morning,
uh,
taking your last final because
they tend to go to the 23rd,
you can just blow off those days and go
off to Bermuda or go home or do whatever
you do a and take the oral final,
which we used to cheat and
have it during reading period,
but they caught onto me
and you can't do that.
So,
uh,
they frequently catch onto me.
But so now we have it on
the first two days of,
of,
uh,
the final exam period.
And you sign up for a,
it is not an interrogation.
It is a friendly exchange
about the themes of the course.
Most people,
particularly in this course do that,
but it's not necessarily
advantage to do it.
People who,
this is not the core.
If they're doing working
hard on this course,
as in the one out of five,
they're blowing off,
uh,
then they tend to do that.
And,
and instead of writing for three and a
half hours and getting writing and cramp,
and inevitably our final exam
was in that horrible place,
Osborn Hall,
where you're sort of tilting like this,
like you're leading out of an airplane
and you sit up there for three and a half
damn hours,
you know,
writing your brains out and,
and you can have a sporty
conversation of 25 minutes with,
with,
uh,
one of the teaching assistants
and you're out of there.
So,
uh,
that's what a lot of people do.
Fact,
about two thirds of the folks do that
as a very funny stories about those.
But now's not the time to do that,
especially cause we're being silly.
But most people do.
Do,
do,
uh,
a deveer well,
um,
let me tell you little
bit about the reading.
The books are available at,
at,
uh,
the Yale Bookstore,
the store,
Barnes and noble.
Here you guys,
here's some of the east.
Um,
and the textbook is a good textbook.
It's really good.
And cultural history.
A guy called a chips sour wine.
Charles sour wine is a buddy of mine from,
uh,
lives in Melbourne and Australia.
Um,
and,
um,
it's a good book.
And the other books are in their own way,
sort of classics that you'll enjoy.
Now,
many of you,
if you had French,
anything,
have read a germy now and if
you haven't read your me now,
uh,
now's your chance to read it.
Uh,
Zola was one of the first
great naturalist writers,
and he would go up to the north,
to the Amazon,
to the minds of Anzac up
here in the north of France.
Uh,
and he would go down in the
minds and see how people work.
He would see how 15 year old girls
worked in the mine Katrine who grows up,
uh,
rather quickly in the mines.
And it's a,
as your me now,
it means the budding,
it's a,
it's a reference to a calendar of the
French revolution and also kind of implies
hope.
And it's about what happens when
people try to mobilize these,
these broad guy.
Come on,
hey,
you know,
these,
these workers in,
in,
uh,
in the minds.
And if you've never read it,
I mean,
it's a great,
great,
uh,
novel.
Um,
a life of her own is a book that
I became obsessed with about,
uh,
all about five or six years ago.
Um,
Emily Carr was born in abject poverty
in the High Alps and the oats out,
uh,
near,
the pop them all of a
and the oils out there,
a GAAP up really high
in the mountains here.
And,
um,
she became a school teacher as a common,
sort of a means of social ascension
for poor person from a village.
He was born right near the Italian border,
but just an abject poverty.
She married an anarchist
from the department of the
l Dash where we happen to
live or at least be legally residents
and spend much of our time down here.
And she moved from one school to the next.
And when she was a very old lady,
um,
she led a demonstration to try to protect,
uh,
the,
the her part little part of France and
the Italian border from being exploited
by tourism.
More about that at the end.
And with her tractor,
she led this demonstration.
It was a phenomenal thing.
And she ended up on this very famous
French television show called [inaudible].
Uh,
we've been not people who said that she
was one of the most interesting people
that he'd ever had on the show.
And she died in 1977 so,
and she published her,
her memoirs.
It was called a soup made of,
of wild herbs.
And of course it was translated in English
with that title and then they changed
it to a,
uh,
what did they change it to?
An English,
a life of her own.
And it's about being a
young girl and a woman.
Uh,
but it's an extraordinary thing.
I became so obsessed with it that,
that,
uh,
we drove up there so I could visit every
school that what she had taught and we
actually found somebody that
we knew he wouldn't like her,
cause he was sweeping up the church.
He worked for one of the churches
and she was very anti clerical.
So we actually met somebody who knew
her and the school is now named after,
but it's a wonderful,
wonderful read.
It's just a great,
my family got a little
tired of this and say,
do we have to,
how many more of these places do we
have to see in which this woman taught?
But,
uh,
anyway,
so we saw most of them.
And then I'll read about Moose,
uh,
who was a communist,
became a communist who was a writer in
a World War One and who served in World
War One.
And he wrote a great book,
which is called under fire that my
dear friend and colleague Jay Winter,
it's just written a new introduction for,
and that's about the,
the horrors of the trenches.
It's just,
you know,
it's just the,
the sheer,
it's just,
it's amazing.
It's amazing read too.
And then Mark Block.
And once I had the pleasure when I was
giving a talk at the University of Straws
Book and sitting in Mark Blocks office,
Mark Block,
uh,
taught people like me and,
the way to do history.
I mean,
there were people like me grew up on
reading mark block though I sure he was
much older than me.
Uh,
and he created a way of doing
history called the announced school.
And He,
um,
his first book actually was called,
uh,
the healing kings because in medieval
French times and medieval English times
when a king was crown,
there was this sense that if the
king could cure you by touching,
excuse me,
for touching you.
If you had [inaudible],
which is one which was sort
of a degenerative disease,
it's hard to find people that
have scratch feel anymore,
that king could touch
the person in and curate.
And it became part of sort of the,
of the popular culture of royalty.
And they,
and they try this in 18,
25 with disastrous results.
Uh,
but,
but this was his first great book.
And at the age of about 55,
the war came along and he wrote a book
called strange to feed explaining why in
1940,
France fell so rapidly.
And then he'd been,
he was Jewish and he was fired from
his post and straws Zboo under Vishi.
That is the collaboration
government and World War Two,
because he was Jewish.
And then he caught out
at University of mobile.
Yay.
And then they realized that he was a Jew,
so he was gone.
Then he went back to a
farm that he owned in the,
the Muzak in the codes up
here in near a boring place.
I used to work called gay,
and he sat around and thought,
well,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna do something.
So not at a horribly advanced age,
I would like to think he,
uh,
went to [inaudible],
which was a capital of the resistance
because they have all these things called
taboo in Leon was one reason they're
passageways where you'd keep the silk raw
silk dry.
And so he,
but he got set up by
somebody by French person,
more about this in a minute.
And he was supposed to meet somebody on
a bridge over looking at the Sun River.
The [inaudible] Leon was
at the confluence of the,
of the home and the song,
you'll learn a lot about France in here,
but we don't ask you questions like that.
What two rivers meet in Lille.
Uh,
but he was set up and he was
hitting Easley tortured here.
It was killed.
So Mark Bloch taught us in
a way how to do history,
but he also writing this book taught
us how to think about the past and more
about that in a minute.
And how to think about what happened
in France between 1940 in 1945.
I do a seminar on that,
uh,
next semester and then,
and then what?
And then I forgot one.
I forgot to put one in.
No,
no,
here it is.
Sarah Farmer who sat in the same class
room literally went before it was
remodeled.
I had wrote,
written a wonderful book called martyred
village was first appeared shade
Garima,
uh,
in France.
And it's about a village they know
very well because they used to live in,
in Lemoshe I that in which,
uh,
on the 10th of June,
1944,
uh,
the SS German troops came and
simply slaughtered everybody.
They shot the man and they put the women
and the children in the church and they
killed them.
But what's interesting about that is
why this particular village became the
symbol for martyrdom in France.
Why?
Because it was thought to be virgin.
There weren't resistors,
there weren't collaborators.
It was there,
it was martyred.
And,
uh,
so she wrote this book,
but with more interesting than that is
that the people who did the massacre in
the SS,
and many of them were l station.
Now stations were French,
even though many of them
spoke German dialect.
And so after war,
the war,
they said,
we are the medical,
they knew we were put on trial because,
I mean,
we were in the army cause we were
forced to be because Alsace was a next
directly into Hitler's Reich.
And,
um,
when they were acquitted,
only two people who were
condemned from those forces,
uh,
they had joined voluntarily.
And the other,
the amount of Gary knew where the,
in spite of ourselves,
we're,
um,
uh,
pardon.
There were riots in the most
that they were pardoned.
There were riots in
Chordoma and in straws,
book in El Sauce that
they had been condemned,
uh,
at all.
So identity national identity is very
complex and we talk about the war.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
you know,
it's a sparkling sparkling account.
And what they did with this
village ghoulish you might
say is they left at just
the way it is.
It was on the 10th of June,
1944 they left all the buildings blown
up or caught on fire and have crosses
where people were shot.
And there was a,
used to be a ghoulish museum with a
knife opened up that indicated that they
tried to defend themselves and then
now they put in assaulted demand.
Wow.
Cause her memory site there,
this kind of slick,
but it's fine.
A friend of mine who was a senator
as the president of it there,
but they kept that village just the way
it was and they'd built one next to it
and about 1950 to some
people about your age.
I started to party and somebody
came up with a gun and said,
we don't party in order,
sir.
Gone.
So imagine growing up in a place like
that where the past was so was written not
only in the death of people that you knew,
because everybody you knew who died,
basically one woman got out,
she went through the,
the,
uh,
there was a veto,
a window behind the altar
and she was able to get out.
Anyway.
So those are the,
the reading is great.
So what,
what can I say?
I'm slightly biased,
but the reading is great.
The reading rocks.
Now what about the films as movies?
Um,
inevitably there's paths of glory.
They associate a lot.
Grier,
if you've never seen it
as a Kirk Douglas movie,
that's a good movie.
Uh,
and it's about the mutinies
on the western front,
and it's very,
very good.
We used to say,
well,
come to one on one and it
will be filmed that at a,
we've shown it at 8:00 PM or something,
but nobody ever does that.
They all watch it in the
privacy of their rooms.
Uh,
or you can go watch it.
We'll figure it out.
But the,
it's a really a wonderful movie.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
you'll see a film called Oh,
Voila.
Lays on phone,
sort of Sia children,
you by children.
How many have seen Louie
miles of Wiley's on farm?
Wow.
Many of you seen it's a great film.
It's a true story.
It's about Fontainebleau,
which is south of,
uh,
southeast of Paris.
Sort of a fancy place.
And it's about his childhood
when he was in collage.
Collage is middle school.
You learn about French schools.
My kids have been friends
schools for many years.
So there,
so I know about these places.
Um,
and he,
there was a Sunday one day this
boy showed up in the class.
This is during Vishi.
It's about 1943.
Maybe it's 44.
And he's new and he's,
he's not different.
He's just not from there.
He's obviously from,
from Paris.
And he was Jewish.
And it's about the attempt to,
I mean,
the role of the Catholic
Church and in Vichy is not a,
a very savory one.
The French hierarchy,
uh,
in many priests,
but many priests were very heroic.
And when this particular priest who was
a real live guy called a [inaudible]
father,
John,
uh,
tried to hide this boy in,
in the school so he wouldn't be
arrested and set off to the camps,
but he was denounced by
somebody who was in the militia,
the released what's called,
which is sort of a of military
thugs that worked for Vishi.
And of course it does not have a happy,
happy ending.
And then the last film,
uh,
most of you won't,
won't have seen it,
a call a lot in hate.
I guess you translate that as
hate or hatred and it's up.
I'm very interested in what happened
in the fringe suburbs two years ago.
In fact,
I wrote a instant article on
it for an encyclopedia because,
uh,
some of the work I had earlier done,
it was about the y fringe suburbs in
a European suburbs are different than
American suburbs,
American suburban.
Many of you come from Hillsborough,
California,
uh,
Darien,
Connecticut,
Gross Pointe,
Michigan,
places like that.
That's not what the are in Europe.
Suburbs where people
unwanted by the center go.
And the fear of the suburbs has been
something that by the price per center has
been a very long,
important theme in French history,
particularly written in Paris.
And I'll talk more about that.
And La in,
which was a small budget movie,
became this great success.
And it's a tough movie to watch.
It's tough.
It's verbally tough to watch
and it'll have subtitles,
but as it was done in 1996 or 97,
but it's,
uh,
it's really superb.
So what kind of,
don't want to give everything away,
but what kind of themes
do we have in [inaudible]?
And of course,
uh,
Eh,
in a course like this,
what have I forgotten about?
Oh,
me,
uh,
um,
I'm married and I said
that I still am actually.
Uh,
and,
and at some,
sometimes I feel today
like yesterday that I,
I've,
I'm sort of,
I'm not,
but anyway,
uh,
I have,
my office hours are,
um,
one of my officers,
uh,
Monday one to three in Branford
college where it was master long ago,
k 13 Branford College.
And I'm also like everybody else on
emails and I'll get your emails panicked
emails at three 10 in the morning
and I'll reply at four 45.
So it goes like,
it goes like that.
What kind of seems,
I mean,
talk a little bit about some of them.
Let me just talk about,
oh,
about three or four of them,
just so you can see what hopefully
you were getting yourself into.
And you'll have fun.
You'll learn a lot about
France and tell you that.
Okay.
One theme I'm interested in is,
uh,
well let me tell you about lectures.
First of all,
I do not do chronological lectures.
Well,
an eight in 1882 and then
it was followed by 1883.
I don't do that.
I lecture about what I'm,
what I like to talk about.
What's interesting that will hopefully
make you understand what the big issues
are,
uh,
in all of this.
So that's why it's a good thing to,
uh,
to come to lecture and
also to read the books.
But one of the things I'm
interested in is national identity.
And in fact,
because we kind of have complex,
uh,
you know,
attitudes toward our own identity,
I suppose.
I mean in my family,
but,
um,
if you took an,
a few of you have heard
me say this before,
so forgive me.
Uh,
in 1789,
if you tried to guess
how many people spoke,
uh,
French in France,
you might come up with
80% as a guests are 90 or,
or whatever it was,
about 50%.
Some people were bilingual.
So what did they speak?
Uh,
uh,
well,
I mean,
if you want to remit,
we'll start anywhere you want it.
Breton,
which is a language has nothing to do
with French at all here or I've got a
really funny story about,
it was hard to tell you,
but tell me about Breton priest in,
in a French speaking Breton priests,
but that's another for another day anyway.
Uh,
they spoke Breton here.
Now not isn't considered
technically part of Britain,
Brittany,
but they spoke Raton there,
uh,
which is basically a Gaelic language.
And then if you go up,
you think,
well,
they spoke French there,
uh,
certainly in Normandy,
but they spoke in many parts of it,
parts of a Patois.
And about 1844,
this kind of crazy guy took a big knife
and he slit the throat of his mother and
his two sisters and they were
the police looking for him.
And he was from Normandy.
He lived near call in,
uh,
you know,
in Normandy.
And they found him eating clams and
things for survival on the beach.
And they had to bring in a translator,
somebody to translate it
before he was getting,
uh,
he,
he dictated his life.
The book,
uh,
Michelle from coal,
a famous philosopher got ahold of I
and wrote a preface for it in French.
It was [inaudible] the Ai,
you know,
I call shame.
I May,
I may do a cer media PR riviere
having slit the throat of my,
my mother and my two sisters,
I'm going to tell it like it was,
and he did.
Uh,
but they had them.
The important thing is that they
had to have a translated for him.
And the 1840s,
uh,
when Bernadette [inaudible] in 1856,
I believe that she saw the Virgin Mary,
of course,
they had to have somebody
come and translate their,
uh,
what was a mountain patois influenced by,
by,
by Spanish.
Uh,
but if we'll move north here,
up here,
and there were a lot of
the people I spoke Flemish,
very few.
Now you don't have said no,
this is just kind of fun.
Uh,
I mean,
I love it.
But anyway,
uh,
and then in parts of the van they spoke
a German dialect is very much like
what's spoken in Fribourg in Alsace.
Almost everybody,
as you will see later,
US spoke German dialect.
But it didn't mean if you ask somebody,
are you French?
And they were the reply in German.
Yes,
I'm French.
You know,
that doesn't,
language isn't necessarily tell you
how people feel about their identity.
Some sage once said,
I don't know who it was,
but I love this expression,
um,
that a language is a dialect
with a powerful army.
Look at Spain.
Why was cut to not illegal to publish
until Frankel Croaked in 1975 clutching
the left elbow Santra as of something
rather because custie Spanish speaking
custody with his command economy had
conquered the bosques and conquered a
conquered the catalog.
And so,
um,
uh,
all of this,
what will change and you know,
during this period or if
you move further down,
you get into [inaudible] which
was a US voice of what's,
of why he said,
well,
which were were a,
a next in 1860.
And they spoke in essentially Piedmontese,
they spoken Italian,
uh,
a language.
If you go to provost,
then provost sal is a written language.
Uh,
you know,
you get a sense of that.
If you see a really great movie,
like you want to flow hat,
you know,
with the inevitable as you are,
they probably do is in every
single film made this side,
this side of Disneyland.
He Disney,
he is there.
Uh,
but with Danielle,
oh toy,
who was fantastic,
he had to put one of those things that
Dennis put in your mouth when they're
going to give you a,
uh,
an x ray to make you feel uncomfortable
in order to pronounce perfectly.
This,
this,
this Provence,
sal language it,
and it's not just the accident of anger,
you know,
cuts Vanga or all Fang instead of on five.
Uh,
it's,
it was,
it's a whole language.
And moving along here,
you get down to Catalonia.
This French Catalonia speaks the same.
We still own old ladies down there
who speaks that same language,
spoke down all the way to Valencia,
at least along the coast.
You move in here,
you go to Bosc country.
Besides all the Patois,
you go to the boss.
Country Bosc is only remotely related,
the finish and the Magyar Hungarian.
Uh,
and then you,
uh,
you know,
we've got to,
you got over in the Patois here
you've got Leemoo is an plot.
Patois.
You've got all these languages.
So the only point of interest about this
is that when new people start thinking
that they're French as opposed
to from a certain family,
from a certain village,
from a certain region,
uh,
when did they start seeing
themselves as French?
And this is being hotly debated in
the literature for a very long time.
There are still people
now that live there.
There's a woman who lives near our
village and she's lived in our village.
I mean,
she was born in the next village and
she's lived in our village for 40 years
because she married a guy from the
village and she's from the next village,
about 20 foot ball throws away or more,
a little more than that.
And uh,
somebody as a joke once asked her,
how to,
how do you feel living in this
village after all these years?
And she said,
oh,
sometimes I get homesick.
Uh,
there was a sense that she's,
she'll never be from the village.
He's from somewhere else.
But sometime between 1750 and maybe 1990,
most almost everybody in France
began seeing themselves as French.
And the schools play a major role in this.
And thus all these kids who
grew up speaking Patois or
Provence sal or Gaskell,
I'm forgotten.
Gaskell uh,
around Boldo,
uh,
they,
can sing the mousy as
an acceptable franchise.
They marked you off to be
slaughtered a when do people,
and it's,
when do parents become
freshmen as someone posed?
And it's interesting question
because it tells you a lot about,
you know,
uh,
about,
regional identity and about national
identity and the role they were,
all the schools is important in that
because what happens is that the Virgin
Mary gets elbowed off
the walls by Marianne,
the female image of the republic.
And that's that it starts
with the French revolution,
but it's a very long process
and we'll talk some about that,
but not that much.
Um,
I guess the,
the,
the other two themes I want to
discuss a and not in great detail,
uh,
but,
you know,
are the wars.
I mean,
obviously world war one is unleashes
the demons of the 20th century.
Nobody could have anticipated that
all these empires would collapse.
Antisemitism was out there before
that in Germany and France,
as you'll see with the Dreyfus affair,
all sorts of places.
But,
uh,
we're all one transformed Hitler,
from a man who hated Social Democrats
who hated socialists into a man,
obsessed with killing Jews were a,
one has an enormous impact on,
on the way people viewed themselves in,
uh,
France and in everywhere.
Everybody knew people who died in the war.
It was the defining experience
for the 20th century.
And the violence of the war continues
into the 1920s and thirties.
So you can see the whole period
until 1945 is it even more horrible,
30 years' war than that
of the 17th century.
There are 35,000,
36,000 communes in France
that is administrative units.
Paris is a commune,
but so as a village of 12 people is
a commun 36,000 in World War One.
Only 12 didn't have somebody killed.
France in the 1920s was a
country of widows dressed in,
in,
in black of people missing
limbs or coughing their
lungs out from the poison gas
if they were lucky enough to survive.
Putting huge strains,
which,
uh,
you know,
I'm,
I'm welfare systems.
Obviously it was very important that they
be taken care of in a country in which
the birth rate had stopped in most of
the country in the mid 19th century,
unique in the world.
Uh,
there weren't enough men to go round.
They were dead.
You can go into villages
and towns almost anywhere,
particularly in the lower
must've song trial down here.
And you can find a in towns of,
of just tiny,
tiny towns,
74.
I am a counter.
I count things all the time,
drives me crazy.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
I'll count up the number of people killed
and every church that I go to visit to
look at it,
it's simply extraordinary.
We can't even imagine what that's like.
There are only three people left in
Britain who fought in world war one,
only three.
And there are about 110 years
old or something like that.
But it's difficult to,
to,
to understand,
uh,
what the impact was and the poisoning
of the political atmosphere.
Uh,
the,
uh,
we'll talk about the battle of the Somme.
S O m m e in the battle of the Somme.
Uh,
in the first day of the
battle of the Somme,
the 1st of July,
1916,
there were 20,000 British soldiers
killed in the first three days,
just counting the British.
There were more British soldiers
killed and seriously wounded.
And there were Americans
killed in world war one,
Korea and Vietnam combined in three days,
comparable chilling effects in Russia,
uh,
and in Britain and in Austria,
Hungary as well,
where with the flower of English youth
is used to say whether were hung up on
that old barbed wire,
they were dead.
And your life expectancy wasn't very
good because the foolish military,
uh,
decisions because of a war that ended
up being the war fought in which no one
outside of a few people who had seen the
Russell Japanese war around mucked and
could have ever imagined.
Uh,
we,
you know,
the finest,
some of the finest books
on any topic are those,
uh,
of history or those on world war one.
The Great War and modern memory,
uh,
of the British have Siegfried SAS
soon about Siegfried SAS SAS soon.
And Wilfred Owen,
who's,
uh,
who's mother got the news that he'd
been killed on the day of the armistice.
Uh,
you know,
there's an extraordinary literature.
The close come Kohona they're
close to a competition for that.
Uh,
richest literature would be the Spanish
civil war with Orwell and Bork and,
and,
and Brennan.
But we'll talk a lot about world war one,
how it started,
what it meant and what the impact was.
And there's nowhere you can go in northern
France where you're not just a wash
with,
uh,
with military cemeteries around Ras.
There any,
we're up in the end near
the showman did dom,
these are battlefields in which,
which every day in fact,
the,
the bottle,
the battle of Somme,
there's one casualty for every
meter of the entire front of,
of the war.
I mean,
a,
of that particular battle.
I mean,
it's really extraordinary,
man.
It goes on and on and on and on.
And we'll talk about the impact of what,
what,
what this happened.
I mean obviously impacts,
but what happened on,
on,
uh,
an on civil society and on politics where
we're the leaders of the 20s and the
30s,
they were dead.
They were dead healed at 18 killed at 19.
I was in the British war museum,
Imperial War Museum the other day,
and I'd been there four or five times,
and I went,
and it's a hell of what they have,
a thing where you can look up dead people.
Uh,
and so I said,
well,
I wonder if there's somebody
with my name was killed.
And there was,
and my uncle had an extremely odd,
my grandfather had extremely odd name
and there was somebody of his name too
that was killed.
They all died.
Uh,
and it was not everybody,
but,
uh,
in France,
1,000,500 thousand people died.
And that's a huge demographic chunk.
It's like a big shark.
Took a big bite out of your basic
pyramid or your demographic,
a tree and someone like Hitler.
I mean,
this isn't a course on Hitler,
but it's from the other course.
But,
uh,
you know why this guy who had
no friends who was just a pain,
just a pain,
he was so pain.
He believes such a pain.
And he had the one guy
that he used to bore with,
you know,
his stories about
architecture and painting and,
and Wagner who we love dearly and in it,
you could never imagine that he
would be somebody that people would,
would listen to on the
radio of hour after hour.
Cause that's how long he talked or that
when Stauffenberg tries to kill him in
1944,
the Germans would pour out of the end of
the street to thank God for saving the
fuel.
Her.
Why did he become somebody Sieg Heil?
He was one of the guys.
He's one of the guy,
he's one of the guys had been wounded
three times and he was a runner that he
carried,
carried messages.
The trenches from the generals were all
drinking champagne and her ass to the
front.
I,
and he was wounded three
times and he was one of them.
He had that,
that,
uh,
that stamp of having been one of the
guys and the violence keeps going.
You have to explain why all of this has
happened and you have to find people
that made it happen.
And it was the Jews and it was a socialist
and it was the communist and it was a
homosexuals and we'll kill them all.
And that's what he did.
And for the point of view of France,
they emerged from the war with the
reality that they are in victory,
a weaker nation than Germany is in defeat.
And so it's a big shadow
over the whole damn thing.
The incredible and Mark Block,
when you read the collapse of France,
it's,
you know,
it's very interesting,
interesting stuff.
World work too.
You know what I mean?
I'll give you two stories.
When I was in,
um,
working in a place called [inaudible],
which is down here,
t u l l e not to have but to,
um,
I knew vaguely that there
had been a massacre there in,
uh,
June six,
1944.
And then a lot of people had been hung.
I didn't have any money,
you know,
my kids would say,
Oh dad,
not that I don't have
any money story again,
but I didn't have any money.
And so I would have,
uh,
you know,
I,
I would be eating ice cream and I got
to know this guy with my not very good
French then,
uh,
and uh,
we talked and I said,
where are you?
You remember the day the Germans
came back and hung all those people?
And he said,
yeah.
I said,
well how did you get away?
And he said,
well,
it's a tool on,
it was a big valleys,
real long town and these
houses have balconies.
So like this.
So he went up and he hid.
He was 12.
He had been killed for Keenan didn't care,
they didn't care.
And,
um,
one day,
so I was eating my ice cream cause
the archives were closed and this,
this woman came up and she was probably
about 50 or something like that and she
ordered an ice cream.
And so this guy says,
well,
you know,
uh,
but on whatever,
madame,
if we a,
you remember that day,
don't you?
When the Germans came back and she said,
oh,
I sure do.
They hung my husband from that poll.
And that poll was right next to,
uh,
next to this ice cream stand in
front of the theater in tune.
And that,
that was 1970 more about that in a second.
And I have a friend is [inaudible] lawyer
who works in that worked in Africa a
lot.
And when he was a little boy,
um,
the Germans came to get his father who
was a Greek Jew and he was taken away and
kill the course.
And one shouldn't forget
that the people who rent,
who rounded up the Jewish
children and the Ma,
hey,
we were,
lots of Jews,
lived,
uh,
were French.
The Germans wouldn't be happy to do it.
We're French police,
they're French police.
And his father was
denounced by a policeman.
Why policemen?
And after the war that policemen directed
traffic at the market every Saturday,
and the widow walked by and saw this
man knowing he had denounced her husband
who had been taken away and killed.
Now in 1970,
there were still this
collective amnesia in France.
The myth perpetuated by de Gaulle,
the big guy,
was it in France?
Everybody had resisted
except for a few elites.
And then France had risen up to follow
his great shadow and it's thrown off the
oppressor and found a republic.
In 1953 there was a documentary made
about the deportation of Jews from Paris.
And there was a film I made about this.
They,
this,
they put together a documentary and the,
in one of the f,
the,
the one of the scenes,
it's a camp place called General C,
which is out near the airport,
halfway to the airport to Yc airport.
And there was a German,
I mean a French gendarme
who is guarding the German.
I mean the French Jews,
French gendarme guarding the French Jews.
And they lifted him out of the movie.
They literally took him off the screen.
So if you see it Iain there,
why?
Because the image was nobody collaborator,
hardly anybody.
And everybody resisted.
Now that Amnesia,
which had Pardot is the gold,
didn't want to give the communists credit
because they were the party of 75,000
martyrs cause they were
organized and they resisted.
Other people did too.
There was a Catholic resistance.
Uh,
there was your golf basic
gaullist resistance.
I'm going to gall died.
I was in Paris,
I was the only person frisk going into
notice ultra dom literally that I saw
that threw me up against the wall.
I'm checking me out
cause I was a kid and I,
and I,
I wanted to go there and see this,
you know,
just for the purpose of
history of being there,
but to go all perpetuated this
myth about the resistance.
And then there were cracks in the myth.
And the first crack was a movie that is
so long that it used to be the janitors
who people who clean these very
nice people who clean these rooms,
used to call it a two six pack
movie because it was so long.
It was,
uh,
it was forced on us was
to say that we're filling,
but,
uh,
there was for you,
you just cut that baby out of there.
But,
but,
uh,
that is about a for a film and it's
called the sorrow and the pity in,
it's about a Claremont fit hall,
which is in the Macias on trial here.
And there's some amazing scenes in
it where they shaved their heads of,
of,
of horizontal collaborators,
which is sort of a crude
way of talking about,
you know,
French women who slept
with German officers,
horizontal collaboration.
Uh,
and at the end of the movie there was a,
there was a,
uh,
Maritia Chevelle,
Yay.
Risha by Aa was a crooner.
He was a singer.
He was a,
if your parents knew about France,
he was the person that your
grandparents even had heard about.
And he was somebody from a poor
part of Paris and for many,
multiple.
And he had a straw hat and he sung tunes
and value good my boys and all of this
stuff.
And at the end of the movie he says,
you know,
there are these very bad rumors about
the me and a that I sang for the German
troops.
And I want to tell you,
I only sang for z boys.
That is the French,
uh,
that has for the French
intern soldiers in,
in,
in Germany.
Then,
you know,
it may have been true or May,
maybe not,
but it made people start
looking at the past.
What really happened between
1940 and 1945 or 44 to 44.
What really happened?
There was a trial of a very old
man in 1998 about called Merissa.
Poppo tried in bold doll and
he did very well after the war.
He had signed during the war,
all sorts of slips that sent Jews off
to the station and the gas national and
Boldo to the train station to
be shipped off to the east.
But he did very well.
He became a minor Gaullist official and
he did very well and they finally caught
up with him and he said,
I'm a good bureaucrat.
I did.
They were pleased with my work.
I signed those fees,
those,
those formulas.
And if I hadn't been there to save the
hundreds and they all would've died and
he was converted,
you can't put somebody 90 years old,
uh,
in,
in the slam air.
And so he was in kind of this very,
very minimum security.
And he finally just croaked,
uh,
a while ago,
one point that he tried to,
he escaped actually with help with some
friends and they found him dining and an
elegant Swiss restaurant.
It was too,
it was a total bull.
But anyway,
um,
so the other thing that
happened was a friend of mine,
I'm very proud to say,
called Robert Paxton wrote
a book called Vichy France.
And he had used captured German documents
because the French documents weren't
open.
They were not available because the big
secret of collaboration should not be
known.
And we're going through,
and Francis,
same thing now with,
um,
uh,
with war of Algeria too,
but more about that later.
So,
give me two more minutes.
I'm going to end in a few of you.
Uh,
the faces have heard this before.
People that I know,
but,
um,
I guess one reason why I'm in history,
well because I read a book a long time,
but I didn't know what else to do.
Uh,
and uh,
I'd read what we read one book that
really influenced me but also read a poem.
And this is kind of a,
uh,
you know,
a signature and not my signature,
but,
but the kind of course it is
because you're going to hear about,
but the gall,
and you're going to
hear about fancy people,
uh,
and you know,
Eh,
but you're also gonna hear about very
ordinary people who were caught up in kind
of the torrent of the 20th century,
in the late 19th century.
So let me just read you this poem.
It is short and it's a Brecht poem
and his called a worker reads history.
Then you can go home or go shop
shop til you drop whatever.
Who built the seven gates of seeds?
The books are filled
with the names of kings.
Was it kings who hold the craggy blocks
of stone and Babylon so many times
destroyed?
Who built the city up each time in which
of Lima's houses the city glittering
with gold live.
Those who built it in the evening
when the Chinese wall was finished,
where did the masons go?
Imperial Rome is full of Arcs of triumph.
Who reared them up over whom
did the Caesar's triumph?
Byzantium lives in song.
We're all her dwellings,
palaces.
And even in Atlantis of the legend,
the night the CS rushed in the drowning
men still bellowed for their slaves.
Young Alexander conquered India.
He alone,
Caesar beat the Gauls was there
not even a cook in his army.
Philip of Spain wept as his
fleet was sunk and destroyed.
Were there no other tiers?
Frederick the great triumphed
in the seven years war.
Who triumphed with him?
Each page a victory at whose expense?
The victory ball every 10 years.
A great man who paid the Piper.
So many particulars.
So many questions.
And if you hang around,
which I hope you will,
we'll get to the bottom of some of this.
Have a good weekend.